Hank: Good morning John, and congratulations
on the release of The Fault in Our Stars trailer,
it was fantastic! But I have to say, that
I'm a little bit upset.
You might not even know this, but the release
of that trailer happened roughly at the same
time as the release of a short film that I
did with Michael Aranda. And I feel, like
it's kind of been overshadowed and nobody's
seen it because of all the TFiOS mania.
SO, I've decided that I'm gonna show it to
you all right now. Without further ado, ladies
and gentlemen, this is Hank and the Tree.
Yeah. Uh-huh. Michael and I did that as part
of the World Builders campaign. World Builders
is kind of like the Project for Awesome, except
that it's run by authors instead of YouTubers.
For every $10 dollars you donate, you are
entered in a chance to win one of hundreds
of signed books, by dozens of authors, and
when they reach certain milestones, like in
my case 350,000 dollars, people do weird things.
So check it out, there's a link in the description.
Now, as wonderful as Hank and the Tree is,
TFiOS trailer is amazing and I've watched
it like 50 times. So here are some of the
things that I have noticed. In-depth review
of The Fault in Our Stars trailer.
Hazel's mum drives a 2012 Honda Accord - a
sensible choice. Monica drives a green Mitsubishi
Eclipse, which is not what Monica drives in
the book. In the book she drives green Ford
Thinderburp- Thunderburp?! She drives a Thunderburp!
Hazel apparently likes Pink Floyd: this shirt
is really old, like, Laser Show Pink Floyd
shirt, that you can't get anymore, but I found
one on eBay and I bought it!
She also likes Imagine Dragons, that poster
is from a show that they did in Denver. I
don't know how she got there...
AND, Hectic Glow Poster!
Her wardrobe is as expected; Chuck Taylors;
purple bra; Ceci n'est pas une pipe shirt.
And of course, Augustus is wearing his signature
leather pterodactyl jacket. Not, it's not
made of pterodactyl leather, though that would
be amazing. People at the warehouse just noticed
that if you look at it a certain way it looks
like a pterodactyl.
Important TFIOS landmarks include the Anne
Franke house, the bridge where John once stared
at us, the Literal Heart of Jesus, and the
vaguely paedophilic swing, seeking the butts
of children.
The "HG" on the ceiling probably stands for
"Hazel Grace", but maybe it stands for "Hank
Green", you don't know! And what's this on
the nightstand, a piece of paper, what is
that, you think it could be maybe a Venn diagram?
John, thank you for helping bring something
so cool into the world I am extremely excited
for you, and for me. I want to go see it and
it's still five months away?!
I know this has got to be a really freaky
time for you, like, I'm sure you are super
anxious, but it is going to be fantastic.
Congratulations, and I'll see you on Tuesday
(cut to black)
(Hanklerfish plush swims into frame)
Blub blub blub blub blub blub blub!
Oh my gosh it's a Hanklerfish! They're real!
Available for pre-order at dftba.com and if
you want to get one of these posters you can't
cos' they were only available during the Project
for Awesome, I'm sorry!